welcome everybody to the Whitney and
Betty macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale we are
fortunate today that actually Whitney
and Betty McMillan are with us so thank
you for being here today we're delighted
to host ambassador Christopher Hill as
this year's George Herbert Walker junior
lecturer in International Studies also
with us today is the Honorable George
Herbert Walker the third yell class of
nineteen fifty three and mrs. Walker
George Herbert Walker the third is a
former US ambassador to the republic of
hungary and he established this lecture
series more than a decade now go now in
1986 in memory of his father a
distinguished graduate of the yale
college class of 1927 the walker lecture
is a signature lecture presented by the
Macmillan sentra each year and has
featured ms eminent policy practitioners
such as Madeleine Albright Richard
Holbrooke and mamphela ramphele
Christopher R hill was sworn in as
Assistant Secretary of State for East
Asian and Pacific affairs in April of
2005 ambassador Hill is a career member
of the Senior Foreign Service whose most
recent assignment was as ambassador to
the Republic of Korea in February of
2005 he was named as head of the US
delegation to the six-party talks on the
North Korean nuclear issue previously he
has served as US ambassador to Poland
for four years between 2000 and 2004
ambassador to the Republic of Macedonia
1996 to 1999 and special envoy to Kosovo
1998 to 1999 he's also served a special
assistant to the President and Senior
Director for southeast european affairs
in the in the National Security Council
ambassador Hill received the state
depart
Distinguished Service Award for his
contributions as a member of the u.s.
negotiating team in the Bosnia peace
settlement and he was a recipient of the
Robert S Fraser award for peace
negotiations for his work on the coast
of a crisis I'll be turning over the
podium to ambassador Hill in in a minute
his speech will last for about a half an
hour I will then have time for some
questions and discussions at the end of
which I will invite all of you to please
join us at a reception upstairs the the
title that ambassador Hill has chosen
for his lecture today's Pacific
perspectives US diplomacy in a rapidly
changing age Asia I'm pleased to
introduce ambassador Hill welcome thank
you very much for that very kind
introduction and thank you especially
for not reading the entire official
state department bio because when you
get to the bottom of the bio they list
languages that at a certain point in
your life you spoke a few words of but
it you know makes you sound like some
incredible polyglot and on the bottom of
it it says you know he speaks polish and
my polish is ok it says polish
Macedonian I I do have some Macedonian
and then it goes on and say and he
speaks Albanian which I I've got a few
words than I'm looking out in the
audience and there's vets and sirois
here from preached in unvetted knows
that I don't speak Albanian so I was
really kind of worried that that would
that would come up but I was spared that
but so C and E how are you good to see
you good to see you it is a it really is
a great pleasure to be here and to to
have the opportunity to to give this
lecture i'm so honored by i'm so honored
by the presence of the Ambassador miss
Walker who we were together when when he
was ambassador in Budapest and i was in
back
in Warsaw I think we got together I
don't know every few months or so we
kind of get the gang together and we
talk about problems of sort of
transition issues as these countries
were not only becoming members of NATO
which they had just accomplished but
then went on to become members of the
European Union and as they became
members of the Union the European Union
they still retain their status of very
good friends of the of the United States
and so those of us who had the honor to
serve in those countries at the time
during this transition where in Europe
we had to you know make sure people
understood that more of the European
Union didn't mean less of the United
States it was a it was a great
opportunity and a great privilege
privileged to serve there so it is a
great honor to be at this university
which has so much history and it's
contributed so much so significantly to
American public life over the last four
centuries it's also an honor to be here
at the Macmillan Center which has I
think in and of itself probably a more
prestigious history than many many
full-fledged universities around the
country but one of the reasons I like
being in Yale is I'm almost back to my
home state in Rhode Island so i can i
can almost see it from here and when you
get to New Haven you you can really feel
that you will soon be fully in red sox
country and so it's a i feel a real real
pleasure to to be here I'd like to talk
about Asia generally and maybe make some
even broader points after that I know
that I am some people think I have I am
the assistant secretary not for
asia-pacific but rather from North Korea
and I want to assure you that yes North
Korea is important and I'll get into
some of that but it is very important
that we keep a broad perspective on this
truly fascinating part of the part of
the world just a few weeks ago I was in
actually two weeks ago I was in
Indonesia I was in Singapore I was in
East Timor place that many people
may have forgotten about but is still
very much there and very much indeed in
need of a lot of help and it was a real
good reminder of the fact that the
United States I think is very much a
player in that part of the world and we
very much need to be continue to be
engaged there are many different issues
issues that we deal with you know if you
look at China in and of itself I mean a
lot of people look at China in terms of
a couple of main issues but it is truly
amazing what when you come into the
office in the morning and you see what
has happened overnight in China whether
it's a land protest in a rural area in
China or or some sort of economic
development there's the natural
disasters as well I mean China's just
immense immense and its scope immense
and its possibilities and immense really
in its problems if you go to Indonesia
there there are extraordinary number of
issues going in this enormous democracy
country of some 230 million people you
know I'd come out of working in Europe
especially working in the Balkans and
looking at some of these these states
with you know 1.8 million people no
offense veteran but I'm just mentioning
that 1.8 million i think macedonia is
about 1.8 million or 1.9 million bosnia
kind of a huge place at four million
then you come over to Asia and you look
at you know consular districts in Chen
do with 220 million people it really
does it is quite a sobering sobering
thought and to to get around and see the
diversity of Asia I mean I went to in
Indonesia if you're in Java that's one
part of the country but when you get to
Papua that's quite another part of the
country and to see some of the problems
people grapple with to look at all the
success that is the growth of the
economies there and then to see that
guess like every like every part of the
world like every every class there's
someone always a little further behind
and indeed when we look at
burma we see a real tragedy of a tragic
country that is not able to make the
kind of progress that other other places
in the region have made you know if you
go back to the 1950s and you see what
people were predicting in terms of who
would be a success in asia burma was
always on the on probably the short list
of countries to be successful and yet
they have made I think made a some wrong
decisions and wrong political decisions
they have a government there that is
simply not meeting the needs of its
people and have not been meeting the
needs of his people not just for a few
years or a few months but for decades so
a very sad situation and then you see
you see some of the breathtaking changes
in a very positive sense that have gone
on in Asia South Korea a country that
I've lived in for some five or six years
to see what what has been accomplished
there and so it is really extraordinary
to see all of these countries together
and yet having such enormous diversity
and I think as you travel around in Asia
you're kind of struck by the sense that
there is a yearning for a sense of
community that I think has not been
developed yet yet in Asia and I think
part of the work that we do in the
six-party talks this air this effort to
try to get together to get all the
players together that is China Russia
South Korea Japan and the u.s. to try to
convince North Korea first of all to
convince each other that this is not a
u.s. problem this is everybody's problem
then to convince North Korea that it has
to do away with these with his nuclear
ambitions and yet to you realize that
one of the things we're beginning to
actually accomplish in the six-party
talks is in fact to build I think a set
of relationships among states that could
be the basis for some sort of
multilateral process well into the
future even beyond the the problem of
North care
is nuclear ambitions indeed I would say
that already in the six-party process
you can see that the US and China have
been able to work together in that
process in a way that really could not
have been foreseen in the past that is
we work on very practical issues
together we have Kim jong-il to thank
for that indeed I think the North
Koreans have been very helpful in
bringing the US and China together there
but we see also some other relationships
that have have gelled in a very in a
very positive way we see Japan and China
continuing to work together there even
when their bilateral relationship was on
was on much more much more difficult
foundation so I think as just as any
good architect will tell you that you
need a good design and a good team you
need to indeed to to have all that to
build a political structure that that
can last I think the u.s. certainly
shouldn't put itself in the position of
telling Asians how to build that
community but I think it is fair for us
to try to be in the position of showing
that we want to be a part of that
community and that in a very real sense
we consider ourselves not only a Pacific
nation but in many respects in an Asian
nation I think one of the difficulties
of building this kind of multilateralism
and this community in in Asia is I think
Asia has been much more based on on a
sort of vertical links on a sense of
hierarchy you know a lot of a lot of
Americans don't like to look to Europe
for what what they have done it seems so
passe but in fact what Europe has done
what Europe has constructed in terms of
relationships among states is really
quite breathtaking if you look at what
they've done since world war two and if
you look at the historical antecedents
before that Europe has done a remarkable
job of cobbling together of dealing with
with old problems and of trying to bring
people together at a table and two deal
with each other on a prince
of equality and yet so Europe has been
able to develop I think much stronger
horizontal lines whereas I think Asia is
still bedeviled by this concept that if
China is up then somehow Japan must be
down and that it's difficult to imagine
a situation where both Japan and China
can be doing very well and yet that is
precisely the situation we want to see
developed we want to see that a
cooperative community and to inculcate
the notion that a cooperative community
not just an individual country I think
we'll be better equipped to deal with
all the challenges we face which
obviously go beyond the borders of any
nation state and we need to I think
create the notion or help foster the
notion in Asia that there is a concept
of win-win I mean I always noted when I
was talking to the North Koreans and I
mentioned the concept of you know
everybody can win out of this process
when when and first of all the
interpreter didn't have a word for that
so it came out win-win and the North
Koreans are looked at me like I was
talking about a North about a Burmese
general or something but in fact when
win is precisely the concept that I
think we need to do more of and help
inculcate in in Asia I think in
particular when you look at the our
relationship with China and I speak at a
university that has had such a special
relationship with China and the China
Law Center and other important exchanges
I think it really put Yale on the map in
China and put China on the map and at
Yale so I'm struck by the fact that we
are seeing when we look at China today
we are really seeing history in the
making its development in the past
generation has been one of the great
stories of our lifetime indeed I think
you could argue the development of China
has been the story of the century so far
and you know when you look at these
kinds of big stories I mean in
Washington you know everybody everybody
indeed
as a has an opinion about China in fact
some people have several opinions about
China China is is something that no one
is really ambivalent about they like it
or they don't like it and I think we
have seen that whether we like it or not
we have to have a productive
relationship with 1.3 billion people
it's not going to be easy because
frankly speaking the United States and
China don't always agree and we have a
lot of differences with China we have
differences with China on issues such as
Burma which is one of China's
neighboring states we differ with China
on on how to deal with the problem of
Iran's nuclear ambitions but I think we
also see that within China there is a
growing openness and that if we can step
back from the reports and daily
newspapers we can see that there are
really some positive trends there and to
be sure there will be some very very
difficult problems ahead and indeed
problems in the months ahead the Tibet
issue very much comes to mind but what
we need to do is to have a kind of
relationship with China where we can
bring up these issues and the Chinese
don't see that don't see us is trying to
bring up issues such as Tibet in a way
that we are looking to undercut or
humiliate China or kind of push China
down but rather we're trying to address
issues that frankly are or should be of
common common concern I think our
president particular has really reached
out to China and made it very clear that
he wants to see this this relationship
with China grow as i go to Southeast
Asia I'm I do think of the fact that you
know this is a region of the world that
has very close relations with the with
the US and yet there's much more of
China in Southeast Asia but if you look
at why Southeast Asia has had very
positive growth rates in recent years
you see places like Indonesia with six
percent even Philippines with
five and a half or six percent you can
see that a reason for why Southeast Asia
has been able to grow is that finally
the world does have a have a second
engine of development and that second
engine of development as China is is
China and so just as those of us
representing the United States in in
Eastern Europe contemplating the entry
of these countries into the common
market just of us just as we were very
aware of how to how these countries were
trying to balance more of the european
union with a continuing relationship
with with the United States I think the
countries of Southeast Asia also want to
see more of China because China has been
a such a stimulus to their economic
growth but it doesn't mean they want to
see less of the United States and indeed
i think Southeast Asia is an area where
the US and China can can work together
so as we deal with the problem of having
a relationship with the 1.3 billion
people I think we do have to sort of
look and see how how to conduct that
relationship and it's pretty clear that
finger wagging and lecturing really
doesn't work I mean it doesn't work with
my kids and it doesn't work and I'm sure
it doesn't work with the leadership in
China or elsewhere we have to figure out
ways to sit down and talk and you know
it's instructive to see during that
during the Korean War when or at the
outset of the Korean War are only
conduit our only source of communication
with the Chinese leadership in Beijing
was through an indian diplomat stationed
there and today with China we have some
57 official official dialogues with
China I mean over more than one a week
we're talking to them and all kinds of
issues whether its food safety tariffs
whether it's law enforcement issues
global warming new technologies we're
really developing this kind of broad
relationship with China and I think what
is even more more heartening is the fact
that we have these people to people
exchanges with China you know when
go about when you walk through Beijing
you will see American students
everywhere you'll see American business
people everywhere see Americans from
from heartland of our country speaking
Chinese and learning to learning Chinese
and it's pretty hardening that we're
able to have this kind of kind of
relationship and I think this is a these
are things that we can feel very
positive about but in having this
positive relationship with with China we
also need to bear in mind that we have
other extremely important relationships
in Asia and that these relationships
don't need to suffer as a result of our
relationship with China one that comes
to mind is Japan Japan is the world's
second largest economy it is the home to
so much new technology in the world it
is a country that truly as the South
Korean president said to President Bush
in Camp David last weekend Japan is a
country that truly shares our values of
democracy and of market economy and so
as we go forward with China we don't
want the situation where it appears that
somehow we have we are undervaluing this
very special relationship we have had
and will continue to have with China
with Japan the US has a treaty
relationship with Japan deed we have
treaty relationships all through East
Asia with Japan with the Philippines
with South Korea with Australia and with
Thailand and so these treaty
relationships really are essential to
our to how we conduct ourselves in East
Asia and a bilateral way but i think
they help anchor the u.s. position there
so getting back to the six-party talks
there is to be sure much work to be done
to to finish this job and as we approach
it we are working very closely with our
partners we are working closely with
China we're working closely with with
Japan with South Korea
and and with with Russia as well we are
looking we are looking for ways to get
through a process and to implement
something that we set up in September 05
and that is a joint statement which
calls on North Korea to to do away with
its nuclear aspirations needless to say
it hasn't been easy and it continues to
be a very difficult process but
certainly progress is being made we have
a team led by an American team
representing the six parties who are
there in North Korea were there as of
this morning led by the director of the
Korea desk from the State Department a
guy named Sung Kim and sung called me up
were a little bleary-eyed from having
spent three days in North Korea he came
through through the DMZ this morning and
reported on where we are in these
discussions and we are I think it is
fair to say continuing to make to make
progress as you know today there were
some I think important events about the
North Korean nuclear activities and
especially its proliferation activities
with respect to with respect to Syria
these issues have been the subject of
six-party talks and they will continue
to be discussed in the six-party talks
the information we've shared with
Congress I think is really a test to our
vigilance with regard to North Korean
nuclear activities and really serves to
underscore the urgency of using the
six-party process and all available
tools to ensure that North Korea has in
fact ended its illicit nuclear
cooperation with Syria and with any
other country and to prevent North
Korea's ability to engage in such
dangerous activities in the future
addressing North Korea's proliferation
activities is very much integral to
achieving verifiable denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula and ending the
threat posed by nuclear North Korea in
july two thousand seven we began a
process of shutting down and
disabling the three core facilities at
the nuclear complex in young beyond and
in so doing we have effectively halted
North Korea's ability to produce weapon
grades weapons-grade plutonium which is
really the key ingredient of the nuclear
weapons program we have been there are
three main elements of this nuclear
complex there's a fuel fabrication
facility there's a nuclear reactor
there's also a reprocessing facility
where you take the rods from the nuclear
reactor and process those into plutonium
all three have been disabled and it is
our hope as we get to a next phase that
they will not only be disabled but they
will be dismantled as well we have in
this current phase we have been leading
efforts to press North Korea to provide
a full accounting of its nuclear
materials facilities and programs
including its ambitions for nuclear and
uranium enrichment and proliferation
activities and I think our efforts are
very much reflected in the october seven
agreement 07 agreement in which North
Korea agreed to provide a complete and
correct declaration and committed not to
transfer nuclear materials technology or
know-how so we will look to when our
delegation gets back from Pyongyang gets
back to Washington probably tomorrow
night at some point we'll sit down and
see how far or see what additional
measures additional steps we were able
to agree with with the North Koreans and
we'll see whether we can get the access
that we need to help develop a sharper
visibility regarding North Korea's
nuclear activities so we have we know we
have a ways to go we are working very
closely with the Chinese with all our
other partners to establish verification
and monitoring mechanisms to ensure that
all parties including the North Koreans
live up to their their commitments in
the six-party process and once there is
a declaration submitted to the Chinese
we will look at it very carefully to
assess what our own
the requirements will be and so as the
Secretary has stated verification is the
key to all of this there is no trust me
in the six-party process it is all about
our ability to verify commitments that
people make and we will make sure our
verification regime within the six
parties can deal adequately with these
problems so we look forward to
continuing to work with these partners
and to get through the end of what we
hope will be this of this phase and move
on to what we hope will be the last
phase which is the the phase in which
North Korea will declare its nuclear
materials what precisely they have and
then we will set up a negotiation to
have them turn over these nuclear
materials that is these fissile
materials and see if they can be given
to the international community and North
Korea would then be denuclearized and
would return to the non-proliferation
treaty so we got a long way to go but
the practical problem-solving and
innovation our team has displayed in the
six-party process i think is an example
of what America can do in Asia and in
the world and you know this does sort of
raise a broader question which is what
type of involvement with Asia and world
best suits the United States I think for
230 plus years it's obvious that you
can't really have a one-size-fits-all
approach the world around us is just too
complex for that so with all the
complexity out there and given some of
the painful experiences since the end of
the Cold War there are those who at
times will advocate a sort of rail
politique approach to to foreign affairs
let's just be realistic pursue our
interests it sounds pretty positive and
what's really what's the matter with
being realistic but I think in fact if
you look at the United States and you
look at our history the problem is that
real politic is just not quite
representative of what is in our
collective DNA as a country and really
you go back for almost four
hundred years and probably as long as
Yale has been here we have an image of
ourselves as a nation that is indeed
special the city upon a hill as John
Winthrop said in 1630 and this I think
very seductive image has translated into
actions and policies over the years it's
included a tendency sometimes where we
proselytize to try to win people over
we've also had other things like
manifest destiny as an example where
where there has been submitted ly quite
some negative experiences for us around
the world over time and so against this
backdrop I think we realize that a real
politic approach to the world cannot
adequately reflect who we are as a
country it's really too small a concept
to really fully animate our global
relationships the fact is that the
United States frankly means more to the
world and the world does expect to see
us live up to our values and in fact I
think Americans expect to see us live up
to our values but you know a funny thing
happened on the way to that city upon a
hill ideal and it was called the 20th
century it was a century of seriousness
were some big and some very tragic
things happened a couple of world wars
protracted cold war the dropping of a
nuclear bomb of two nuclear bombs and
the United States began to have to deal
with the world in a very pragmatic and a
very indeed a very sober way but as the
1990s came the end of the Cold War
brought back I think some of this
international idealism that Americans
have had over the centuries and of
course we're not just talking about the
government because since the 1990s one
of the big changes in how we conduct
foreign policy or hell frankly any
conduct any country conducts foreign
policy is that there's been an explosion
of American non-state actors involved in
foreign affairs life of our countries
when you look at nongovernmental
organizations and other private groups
they are just increasingly active all
over all over the world indeed for many
inhabitants of developing countries they
first and only interaction with an
American they will not be a US diplomat
or US government official but rather
maybe an NGO so NGOs play a very
important very productive role their
advocates they also do a great deal of
humanitarian work but what we see in the
in the light of the the the end of the
Cold War the emergence of the u.s. is
that sometimes as Americans have gone
out in the world we have had and express
our expression of idealism has sometimes
taken a certain form of triumphalism to
be sure our values have been triumphant
and there we should not be ashamed to
say that but telling other countries
what to do and doing the equivalent of
end zone celebrations or imposing our
values this is proved to be especially i
would say in asia an ineffective way to
inspire our people and inspire people
and their their governments american
values very much do energize people in
particular what we have done far more
than really what we have said is
important and i would say our 200 year
example of democracy of inventiveness
economic and social openness has been a
true inspiration to Asians and I see
this wherever I go in in Asia so as we
approach Asia and the rest of the world
we need to somehow synthesize those
values that is our humanism our
reverence for education and invention in
fact frankly our openness with a
pragmatic realistic view of the world
and to make sure we always do this with
a great measure of humility I think
Americans will figure this out I think
we can be that great example to other
countries and I think we have a lot to
offer but I think we need to we need to
do this in a way that we set this
example and people people will follow us
and so doing I think yael with it's
inspiring international pedigree is
already playing
role in this the Yale China Law Center
which has helped China chart a course
leading to genuine rule of law is a good
example of what this kind of production
productive activities where we set an
example and people will follow this
example we see Yale scholars and
professors and ambassadors to spread out
across Asia and represent I think the
best and most thoughtful side of our of
our country and I hope Yale will indeed
keep this up and I want to thank you all
and tell you what a great honor it's
been to hear it's been to be here at
Yale and I look forward to your
questions thank you yes sir
well with the understanding that Iran is
not in my parish I would again I'd
caution on the idea that there are you
know sort of one-size-fits-all and we do
have a multilateral approach with with
with Iran you know in North Korea we're
dealing with a country that has not only
produced fissile material but proudly
produced fissile material they've
actually exploded a bomb in October 06
so there's a certain it's a different
dynamic from from Iran where we have a
country that continues to deny that it's
even engaged in this in this weapons
weapons program I'm not in really a
position to recommend that what we do in
North Korea or with North Korea can
apply to the situation in Iran except to
say that you know you have to really
work on it every day there's no macro
management of this you've really got to
be engaged on it every day and we try to
work it step by step with the North
Koreans not that we want step by step I
mean I would prefer to have them wake up
one morning make a strategic decision to
get rid of these weapons of mass
destruction and be done in time to you
know watch the Red Sox that evening it's
not going to happen I mean we need to
work this every day and through the day
and try to break this up into small
chunks and see if they if we can coax
them along and see if they believe that
they're in a better position by moving
them and then whether they'll go further
the problem with a step-by-step approach
is you know you do have things that
happen along the way you have you know
things get hung up and people think the
process is over it's not but you know
you do have good days and bad days so
again I I think Iran has a certain view
of itself in the Middle East and North
Korea has a certain view of itself in
Northeast Asia I think they're rather
different views
look at a map North Korea is the
smallest country in Northeast Asia a
much smaller tiny economy compared to
anyone else I think Iran is a rather
different aspirations for itself in the
region and that may lead you to a kind
of a different approach let me get a
student any student out there yeah
well I don't know if it's surprising but
I think sometimes people in Asia I mean
again I don't want to make these kind of
crass cultural generalizations but when
you're the big guy it's very important
not to be too aggressive about how you
deal with a little guy now in many cases
the little guys causing the problem but
you know people will just look at the
relative size and they'll kind of be
sticking up for the little guy I mean
it's you know happens in the u.s. to I
always root for those baseball teams on
the bottom of the standings but I think
it I think you really have to be aware
of it in Asia and and for a part of the
world that's famous for the sort of
vertical orientation hierarchy big guy
strong etc yeah you really have to be
aware that often there's a lot of
sympathy for the little guy there and if
you're going to pursue it you better be
a little you know show respect to people
and the whole notion of showing respect
to your seniors there's also something
about showing respect to people are not
your seniors so I think you've got to be
kind of aware of these things you know I
don't know if that's uniquely Asian
frankly I think a lot of what you do in
diplomacy you learned in the proverbial
elementary school playground it's good
to have friends good to have allies you
know someone's beating you up in a
playground it's good to have someone
else who'll take care of your problem
for you but I think America as we
approach Asia we need to do it with an
understanding that you know the history
has not always been a good history and
some people will perceive us as
outsiders no matter what we do and I
just think we have to do it in a very
respectful tone I mean when you look at
there's a view in China that
you know the look at the Tibet situation
and you know I think we all know Tibet
situation I mean it's on the front pages
of the newspapers but you know to
understand how Chinese view this it's
not just a government issue it's a
people issue and so you have to kind of
beer that bear that in mind it's you
know I think in general terms Americans
would do better to spend a lot more time
on history and the trouble for me is
when you go to college 30 years ago the
history I studied I really political
science i studied is now history and but
what's interesting is the history I
studied is now kind of political science
you know when I study the break break up
of the Ottoman Empire I never thought
I'd be dealing with the situation of
Kosovo and other places in the Balkans
and to understand the dynamics there you
were wise to check out your late 19th
century history oh yes yeah
well if you turn around you'll see some
people with notebooks and they're not
good students they're just good
reporters so it's probably not a good
thing for me to be speculating on the
stability of the regime in North Korea I
mean they would love me too but you know
I gotta deal with these guys the next
day i would say i would say that you
know North Korea is getting to the point
where they've got to make some choices
and you know these whatever they thought
nuclear weapons were going to do for
them in terms of preserving their you
know their their state they need to
understand that problems you know when
you look at state collapse in the world
usually countries that collapse don't
collapse because someone else comes in
and you know in the 19th century sense
they usually have internal problems and
so I think it behooves countries to pay
a lot of attention to those internal
problems and often those internal
problems their economic problems and so
when you look at the North Korea's you
know I mean I could facetiously say you
look at their top 100 problems you can
look at their top 1000 problems I think
you would agree nuclear weapons aren't
going to solve any one of them so
nuclear weapons have North Korea
resulted in in it being very isolated
now for a North Korean leadership you
don't want to be if you're too isolated
they realize that they're too isolated
that is very problematic for them but if
they're worried about opening up as well
and whether a rapid opening up could
cause you know instability factors so I
would not want to be a North Korean
policy maker right now I think they have
very few few options out there I like to
think that we are providing them a means
by which to get out of this nuclear
business and I think the day they do
that would be a very good good day for
their country yes ma'am
gosh a question now decided by kuvira
yeah well first of all with regard to
the North Korean human rights record if
if North Korea truly aspires to
membership in the international
community they're going to have to do a
lot of things and I would put right up
there on the top of the list improving
their human rights record you know you
could argue well we're you know where do
they start because frankly it's a human
rights record which you know I don't
think would get a very good grade here
at Yale so I think what we would like to
do at some point and maybe at an early
point is if we're talking about bringing
in North Korea and the international
community in the context of our giving
up their nuclear weapons I think it'd be
very useful to have a human rights
dialogue and I think what the North
Koreans need to understand is human
rights or not some weapon that we're
using against them it's not some way
that we're trying to humiliate them it's
frankly if you look at the history of
the human rights movement movement it's
really an expression of dignity of
people and the importance that needs to
be attached to that as a member of the
international community so I don't think
it is useful to talk to them in an angry
tone about it I think it's useful to
talk in a very sober tone to them and
explain that if they do want to be part
of the international community which i
think is the only way they can really
survive i don't think countries can live
apart from the international community
they are going to have to live up to
certain standards and human rights is
one where they are not not there you
know as for the United States you
mentioned a couple of incidents in
recent years but you know frankly you
could go back I mean in my lifetime you
could look at segregation in the south
you could look at racism through you
know many parts of this country you know
in my youth you could look at you could
look at you know
a lot of failings of the United States
in terms of human rights a lot of issues
yet I like to think I mean that our
country has addressed these through a
through an open process and I don't
think any American should get up and say
we're perfect and why can't you be
perfect as well I think what we need to
be clear about is we have problems and
we're dealing with those problems you've
dealt with you mentioned some very
specific policy issues but those
specific policy issues are very much
being being debated discussed in our
government and our courts in our in our
newspapers and so whatever one's opinion
about some of these things I think we
can agree that the United States is
trying to try to work through these work
through these things I had the privilege
of being overseas when I was seven and
eight years old and I remember
foreigners I mean when I was seven years
old and making comments about you know
why do you why do you discriminate
against black people why you do these
things I remember coming home because I
hadn't seen this and talking you know
explained to my mother who's you know
from a very sort of abolitionist type
from Massachusetts and you know she she
explained to me know what was going on
and in places you know in school
desegregation issues and things like
that and I felt this momentary you no
sense of shame that our country it was
doing this you know I was only eight
years old when my god you know but you
know I've come to understand I came to
understand that we're dealing with it
and I think that's our greatest
strengths and our strength is not that
we're perfect our strength is that we
deal with things openly and I hope will
continue to do that yes that's you yeah
well I'm not one of your economics
professors but I'll take a crack at that
one which is if you look at the
composition of South Korean exports to
China and then you look at the
composition of Chinese exports to the
United States you'll see a connection so
I don't think that the fact that you
know component parts going in from South
Korean factories that go into Chinese
you know Game Boys or whatever means
that somehow South Korea is shifting to
China I think it's just part of a very
of an ongoing global globalized supplier
Network you know I was in Camp David
last week with the last weekend with our
with our president and with the new
South Korean president and the South
Korean president spoke in very very
clear terms about South Korea's desire
to have good relations with its
neighbors china and and japan and also
to have this very special relationship
with the US and I look to South Korea to
continue that and and the reason is I
think it's very much in South Korea's
interest they want to have good
relations with those two larger
neighbors but they also want to have a
relationship with a distant power I'm
sure that's a model that some professor
is written a book about by the way read
all you can now because once you start
working it's tough to read I mean I mean
I barely get to the sports page these
days but yeah
yeah yeah yeah well first of all I
there's no question that China shares
our goal about denuclearizing North
Korea there's absolutely no reason in
the world why China would want to see
North Korea continue to develop nuclear
weapons I mean they're a bunch of
obvious reasons for that I mean the
proliferation issues you know the danger
that other countries would feel they
need to develop nuclear weapons etc etc
but you're asking a question really of
how is china prepared to try to achieve
this objective now one of the and I
think one of the answers really does
indeed start with a map you look at a
map and you see China is North Korea's
neighbor and that in fact you know China
could cut off all aid to North Korea and
cause a lot of economic more economic
hardship and and the question is would
that achieve the goal and I think the
Chinese believe it it doesn't and
moreover I think when you look at how
China tries to deal with its neighbors
it's not really the way it tries to
approach that if you're ten thousand
miles away from a country you might want
to boycott the country if you're the
neighbor you might be thinking well
these people are going to be our
neighbors for the rest of history so is
this the way we want to we want to go on
this you might also and because China is
a big country in like most big country's
foreign policy issues sometimes drive
out of domestic politics it's a shocking
thought but it happens and so if you're
in China and you're looking at North
Korea what does that mean to you well
it's a it's a communist state now if
your business leader and Shanghai do you
care maybe not but if you're a communist
party member maybe you do care about
that so that could you know you have
within China you have party elements you
have government elements maybe they have
a different view of this you have
military elements
you have civilian elements maybe they
have a different view you have reformers
in China that is people want to really
move fast on these reforms then you have
people saying wait a minute how we're
going to square this with our marxist
leninism there are a lot of those people
still around your rural or urban issues
and so how would the collapse of North
Korea affect these debates within China
hard to say but they would probably
affect those debates so I think when
China looks at it there are a whole host
of domestic political calculations that
are probably going going into that and
so you know if you look at a newspaper
they use it's often the thing well China
doesn't want to destabilise North Korea
because they're afraid of North Korean
refugees okay I mean I don't rule that
out at all I mean I'm sure that's one of
it but I'm just trying to suggest that
maybe there are a whole host of other
issues that make it tough to make that
what is really a historic decision when
you shut off a neighbor I mean we
haven't had that we've never shut off
Mexico or shut off Canada I guess we've
invaded both at various times but not
lately so you know i think it's a it's a
tough calculation for them what I'm
pleased about is that we are kind of in
sync when we talk with the Chinese on
this issue of North Korea and I think as
we have embraced the six-party process
with China and the chair I think it's we
have been able to come closer to China
as a result of this six-party process
and I'm hoping that this sort of thing
will yield dividends as we continue to
deal with with you know other problems i
mean the problem in Darfur I mean China
has made some changes in Darfur they've
understood that you can't just look at
Sudan as a source of energy you've got
to consider how Sudan is being regarded
you know what kind of humanitarian
situation there isn't so there is
there's clearly an evolution and how
China is looking at some of these issues
and I think it's in our interest to
be with them to try to work through
these problems yes yes
this
I'm sorry what is the concern what is
the valid concern about on China well
you know the six-party process is a
pretty broad strong platform on which
you can do a number of different things
and the idea that you're all going to
six sit there with six delegations I
mean it is it is a remarkable thing when
you have these plenary zai described
this to some audiences where you have
these big white plastic sort of fake
tulips and when you this huge six-sided
table with these this flower display in
the middle of these five tulips then
when you begin to talk they all light up
because interpreters have begun to
translate and so you say well it's great
to be here today and then they all light
up and then you wait for each tulip to
go out meaning that the Korean the rush
and the Chinese the Japanese you know
they've all finished translating your
sentence so you wait and then they all
go out and then you make your nests next
sentence and wait until they all go out
you know you can't really do business
too well doing that you know you spend
all your time looking at white tulips
and say so you know you we've needed a
bilateral process and what is important
for us is to some extent I think the you
know sometimes the North Koreans have
sort of wanted to exact to sort of deal
with the Americans and you know that's
fine but we're going to deal with the
others and we expect these other
relationships to to jail because as I
said earlier when we look at the
six-party talks we see something that
can gel into some sort of framework even
beyond the North Korea some sort of
multilateral framework beyond the North
Korea problem so you know we're not
going to allow the North Koreans and
come to us and and you know talk about
Japan we're going to say you talk to the
Japanese and so I think we're succeeding
in that now with regard to South Korea
Korea's had a had a very important
election in December and and and in
April with the parliamentary election
they moved from a center-left government
to a center-right government and I think
it's important to keep their word center
in there in both cases because you know
South Korea is not an extremist form of
government and but you know I think what
what was important for the u.s.
especially with the centre-left
government which paid a great deal of
attention to the sunshine policy of
dealing directly with the North Koreans
I think what was important for us was to
really respect the history that one of
the great tragedies of the 20th century
was this division of Korea you know when
you think about it no one thought this
would happen I mean we we were talking
about who will take surrender of the
Japanese troops north of a 38th parallel
who will take surrender of the Japanese
troop south of the para 38th parallel no
one thought this would be two different
countries 50 60 years later so this is a
great for Korean people it is a great
tragedy terrible tragedy so if the US
looks like we're always trying to keep
the Koreans from working together we can
create a situation where some people can
say why are you preventing us from
dealing with each other are you trying
to keep Koreans down or keep Koreans
week so I think the u.s. we you know
clearly you know we didn't want a
situation where the South Koreans were
engaging with the North Koreans in a way
that made some of the leverage created
in the six-party talks where we talked
about providing fuel oil to the North
Koreans where that leverage gets
undermined by what's going on in the in
the north-south process so we really
tried to manage that situation making
sure there was good communication
between the north-south process and the
six-party process I think we manage that
and what I like to think is when the
South Korean people came to vote for
their president and for their their new
national assembly the issue of the u.s.
the issue of how
were dealing with these issues was not
an issue you know that the u.s. people
went to those elections you know asking
whether the you know one party could do
better with economic growth than the
other party the sort of thing you like
to see in a in an election so I think we
manage that and now of course they have
a government that I think is expecting
more reciprocity from the North Koreans
the North Koreans have clearly contained
their enthusiasm for this new South
Korean government I think the North
Koreans are going to have to understand
that they have to deal with this and you
know South Korea is going to be
important to them whether they like it
or not and I think in the long run even
in the medium run we're going to be fine
on this yes sir
the incentives for North Korea okay do
you want to get that phone or oh okay
well what we did was we you know in the
1990s there's something called the
agreed framework and basically North
Korea is in constant need of fuel oil
but because they have these very old
Eastern European factories often East
German factories and they require this
very heavy fuel oil this stuff that you
know people familiar with the Navy from
the 1940s 1950s would know what it looks
like very thick black stuff heavy fuel
oil hfo that is a kind of fuel oil that
we like to provide them because they
don't have the cracking facilities that
could turn the fuel oil into diesel or
or in any way run military equipment
it's just a heavy fuel oil that can be
used in certain factories including some
electricity and heating plants so in the
in the 1990s we had something called the
agreed framework and we provided this
fuel oil as long as North Korea kept the
reactor shutdown and it was basically
the best deal we could get out of the
process now what we have is we said to
the North Koreans last spring in order
to shut down the reactor and the
facility will give you 50,000 tons of
fuel oil so we gave them 50,000 tons
boom they shut it down in order to get
more they needed to go more into
denuclearization so going from just
pulling a switch and shutting it down to
actually disabling the facility when
you're disabled it means it's not going
to you can't bring it up very easily
it's going to cost them an awful lot
take them a lot of time so the North
Koreans asked for a lot more fuel oil
for disabling so we put together a pro
and by the way it's not just with the US
we have several other countries in the
six-party process supplying this so we
gave them a total of nine hundred and
fifty thousand tons in order to get
through this the so-called second phase
and with respect to the
the nuclear facilities that was in
respect to several steps to several
steps that would disable the reactor the
reprocessing facility and the fuel
fabrication facility now how much is
nine and fifty thousand tons well it was
we found that it's probably in terms of
their overall need maybe four or five
months of fuel oil now what we've done
is we gave them some fuel oil
equivalents so that when they they
needed some equipment and we worked out
with the Chinese what the equipment
would be and we figured out what it
would be as a unit of this heavy fuel
oil sorry to go into all these details
but I know them and so the result was
that they have used about fifty sixty
percent of the fuel oil or fuel oil
equivalent do them that is not in 50,000
tons they probably gone through the
equivalent about 550 600 something like
that and so in order to get more fuel
oil we're going to have to go even
deeper into denuclearization and what we
anticipate is that after disabling the
facility you know taking part the parts
you know leaving them on the ground etc
we're going to go to a so-called
dismantle meant phase where this stuff
will be carted out of the country and
then we'll probably give them more fuel
oil even for that the real question and
the question that quite frankly keeps me
up at night is when we get to this final
stage and we're dismantling their
nuclear facilities they have this
separated plutonium and in debt indeed
we had a team in North Korea discussing
precisely how much separated plutonium
that is how much plutonium has been
produced out of this facility over the
years and a lot was produced in the last
few years so we have whatever it is 30
40 50 kilos of this separated plutonium
and so in this last stage the North
Koreans will be across the table with
this bomb making material and we got to
get them to give up the bomb-making
material can we do it with fuel oil give
them more fuel oil I mean
it's really going to come down to this
very tough negotiation if we can get
this stuff out of them that will be the
real key to denuclearizing North Korea
yeah
now we have right now we have Russia the
US China and South Korea participating
in this court consortium on fuel oil and
fuel oil equivalents Japan has not yet
participated because they have an issue
with I mean it's a separate issue but it
has to do with the fact the fact that
North Korea abducted some of their
citizens in the late 70s and early 80's
this is a huge issue in Japan it's not
just an issue for the government's an
issue for the the public and so Japan is
not participating until they get a
little progress you know some some step
forward on that so at the other
countries are doing some things for
example you know South Korea is
calibrating what they do north-south
with how we're doing in the six parties
so some calibration they're going on but
any kind of substantial bilateral aid
programs that will probably awake this
next this next phase the US we've agreed
to take a couple of political gestures
that is having to do with removing North
Korea from a list of state sponsors of
terrorism and removing them and so we're
prepared to do that at a certain moment
and similarly we have something called
the trading with the enemy act and it is
one of the authorities that holds in
place sanctions against North Korea now
there are a lot of other authorities
that hold in place sanctions against
North Korea trading with the enemy act I
think what has really exercised the
North Korean about that North Koreans
about that is the word enemy just as
they don't like the word terrorism
because you know they did sign up to a
number of you and covenants they have we
don't have any reports that they've been
engaged in terrorism in over 20 years so
so those are two additional elements
that we're working through yes sir
you
well I'd say
I mean I have personal views on all of
these issues rather strong personal
views but I'm not sure I should be
standing up here and talking about my
personal views of Hiroshima I I'm just
not sure that's enough it's an
appropriate forum to get into that be
happy to talk to you privately about it
I think how to make sure the NPT the
non-proliferation treaty how to make
sure it works how to make sure that we
can deal with nuclear proliferation
pressures because the technology is out
there as we all know and how we do that
I think is one of the fundamental issues
of our day you know climate change
understandably gets a tremendous amount
of discussion and the public but i think
these proliferation issues should should
be seen more broadly as you are doing
than just looking at you know how we
doing in this Iran negotiations you we
have a Six Party Talks the error versus
how are we doing in in North Korea you
mentioned South Asia that's a very apt
place to to to deal with this
occasionally you know the North Koreans
have said you know why can't we have
India why can't we have an India
solution where why can't we you know
what why don't you treat us like India
and then you know you try to patiently
explain why North Korea is not India
yeah it doesn't take long or it takes a
long time whichever you choose you know
I think when you you know a number of
people have looked at this issue it's a
there was a rather extraordinary op-ed
about a year and a half ago that was
co-authored by a number of our former
secretaries of state i think also bill
perry was there i think with Schultz
Perry Kissinger a couple of others and I
think they were really exploring the
issue of
whether in the NPT where it calls for
countries who are the nuclear States
whether you know how should those
countries begin their obligations in the
NPT to build down you know I think it's
when you look at what this
administration has had to deal with with
this global war on terrorism with the
situation in Iraq with you know and then
dealing with non-proliferation issues if
this is quite a full plate but I predict
that the next administration whoever it
is whoever he or she is is going to have
to to deal with this with us with this
issue because in proliferation we just
cannot fail I mean we have a situation
where the technology is is is too it's
it's very difficult to control the
movement to control proliferation you
know this Syria issue that we've talked
about I mean this was a reactor that was
only really discovered as being a
reactor in recent years even though it's
been it was in construction for seven or
more years if I'm not if I'm correct so
you know I think you know there's been
this idea of the proliferation Security
Initiative so-called psi where you try
to work out with other countries certain
standards and means to communicate with
each other clearly we need that sort of
thing but I think we really need a much
stronger consensus than the in the world
that we're going to deal with this
problem because it is really a
fundamentally existential issue I mean
if we ever had a situation where you
know a nuclear weapon is exploded by a
terrorist or some or even exploded in
anger between two countries it will just
change the world as we know it we have
to we have to address this yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean we were we were we
looked at you look at certain indicators
and you may not have identified any kind
of facility for enrichment but you look
at certain purchasing activities and you
ask why they buying that and some of the
stuff is dual use but you know you can
piece together that wait a minute
they're not buying this type of
lubricant for you know bicycles or
something they're buying it for
something else so so you know it's a
it's a very inexact science trying to
put this put this together we have in
North Korea we have a you know there's a
fact there that they have produced
plutonium and we've got to we've got to
succeed in getting them to give up that
plutonium and believe me it's not easy
they need to declare a certain amount of
plutonium what they have and we've had
some very very detailed conversations
and in recent days about that but once
they declare it you know there's no
trust me in this business I mean you
can't say oh thanks very much sounds
about right you know we need there are
certain technical means that you can you
can check this now one of it is one of
the things you look at is production
records just as a as an auditor coming
into a business you know look at the
books and can make certain draw certain
facts from the books but you don't want
to just do that you want to have some
physical access and you want to be able
to use you know some scientific means
and and I would say our country has done
a lot to develop some of these detection
means some of these verification means
but you know you get to the point where
you can find you know a verification
means that you're prepared to live with
me and you know you have to you have to
make a judgment on that my own judgment
is we can get a verification of their
denuclearization I think we can't
achieve it if they cooperate we can
achieve verification will have you know
some people will have more intrusive
ideas about how to do it than other
people but I think I think we can do it
such that when we make a determination
that we can go forward on this I think
you know we have some pretty hard-nosed
people are going to look very you know
very you know with real jaundiced eye at
this and I can assure you if we make the
decision to go forward it's because we
believe we can verify what we go last I
think we have time for one more question
it's yours you know I hate the last
question thing because it's often but
you look like a nice person so go ahead
yeah yeah you've thought of that huh
well you know you'll have to ask them I
my impression from all the campaigns is
you know when the new president comes in
you know checks out the Oval Office you
know checks out the chair behind the
desk the first thing that he or she is
going to have to deal with they would
rather it not be North Korea nuclear
issue so I think there's an incentive
for everyone to try to move this along
but you know I've said many many times I
mean here we are in an end of April some
of the journalists here who are
scribbling down in their notebooks
desperately hoping I'm going to say
something new on this can tell you that
I predicted well if we don't get this
done in February that's a big problem if
we don't get this done in March it's a
big problem and now they're about to
hear me say we really got to get this
done very soon because it's going to be
a big problem right tomo you have that d
write that down there your great article
yeah Groundhog Day therefore you know I
think realistically speaking we got to
get on with that last phase that I
described this phase where we go to
dismantle meant and and i hope the
turnover of fissile material and if we
don't get going on it quickly i think it
will just be not enough days and the
remaining part of a year to do it you
look if the North Koreans want to do
this it can be done but it's with the
the North Koreans they they really you
know every every you know you measure
your political mileage with them in
inches I mean every every issue needs to
be go we go very slowly sometimes we go
slowly because you know we want to make
sure verification means are our adequate
sometimes they go very slow
Lee so it's so we got to really get to
it real quick but if they want to if
they wake up tomorrow morning and say
we're done with all this all that stuff
away we can get it done real quick well
it remains for me to invite everybody to
join us up on the second floor section
and to thank ambassador Hill for it
extremely stimulating and illuminating
talk thank you so much thank you very
much thank you